measuring the our wife something isn't
predicated on just doing it it's
predicated on how good you are at it
this portion is like with me so I think
this is when you need to get selfish
like you'd ask your question hiring is
guessing firing is know like you got to
go fast that's how you get [ __ ] done
that's in figure stuff out this is the
television and the television is the
radio for forties [ __ ] great
let's go right into direct questions
alright so with us being in Denver we
spend so you're in advertising probably
where I'm gonna television pradhan yeah
except do that kind of stuff but we
realize that the way that we need to go
is this way and so we're not familiar at
all so it's a two-part question
first is how do we transition and how do
we measure how the transition Google
should go percentage-wise into that and
where we just opened two months ago and
in ten cases so it's not a good it's not
a grand in and TV yes ten cases ten case
and what would you need for your
business model
well basically our average right now
again the cases we don't know yet but
our fee averages and so if we assume the
same fee then you know we're gonna need
over ten cases a month to break you okay
I'm on spend if I understand um and so
you're asking how to measure the
transition well and launch I got it I
got it
so let's start with Denver there's only
two things you can do one so I'm gonna
jump around and cuz I want to give
answers that I always bring back for
everybody
measuring the our wife something isn't
predicated on just doing it it's
predicated on how good you are at it
right so like this is where people get
caught when with this question the
everything I'm about to say the complete
variable is how good you are at the
thing that includes television the place
where everybody gets caught in
television and Instagram and Amazon and
everything is they get something to work
in their math and then it will realize
that they still have they can still
innovate they're creative to do better
you're getting cases in Denver the
reality is you've been running that same
commercial for so long you might be able
to get if that commercial was better so
one of the great things about digital
versus television is your ability to id8
even when something works so I'm just
trying to make sure we establish that
because that is the big punchline here
when I tell you what I'm about to tell
you which is well it's easy you can take
10 20 25 50 or 75 percent of the money
up in Denver you move it to Facebook and
YouTube and at the end of the month if
you did better against the way you it's
not super hard math the problem is first
of all it takes time for something to
kind of actually creep and which is why
you're seeing a difference in Arizona
versus Denver because by the 13th time
because I listen to the same [ __ ]
radio station that I hear your [ __ ] I
convert verses the first time in Arizona
that's just a big difference that's
brand number two
so in Denver I would do a couple of
things one first you have to feel
confident that you understand how to do
the creative and the media distribution
what's everyone's like digital so great
cool it's also super hard like what
makes it great is what makes it hard
there's unlimited variations and always
constant movement
what made TV and print and radio and
billboards so great for everybody is the
distribution became locked then you knew
you're locking in too and the only
conversation for last 60 years has been
the creative you're not debating how the
Billboard works I guess digital came
along digital billboards that would be
example but in my world tomorrow
Instagram can change a feature that
creates a new arbitrage the actual
distribution changes what is amazing
about digital though is we can do 74
variations of content not just one how
long have you been running the same
commercial in Denver we run them about
six months and then change them that's
good and so do you have like a Hall of
Fame though like if something like you
know that you'll reboot something we do
to a degree but in
Vigil the weird thing is is our guy is a
medical doctor and an attorney and so
he's a unicorn so it cuts through the
messaging compared to all the I
understand deters here's what I would do
if I were you on in Denver I would spend
80% of the month I would spend 80% of
the money that you need to spend right
now on TV and I would force yourself
creatively or look at your Hall of Fame
or push yourselves to get 100% of the
results for 80% of the dollars which
then takes pressure off on you
completely you know skinning your knee
and chipping your tooth and bleeding and
finding your way through digital but
you've got twenty percent of the money
creatively and media-wise
to be able to do that and that would
that's what that's what I would do as
the most conservative as the most
aggressive I would go 5050 but that's
what you need to do you need you know to
me the reason I love giving advice to
take the 80 and make it act like a
hundred you're working with house money
on the twenty percent digital and so I'm
always reminding people like hey it's
not like you're taking this money away
because if you take it away and then
you're hurting you're gonna be impatient
with my [ __ ] and my [ __ ] is testing in
perpetuity
if you guys saw the text exchange
between me and my team I'm changing my
mind forty three times a day like
there's so much because that's what
unlimited distribution and unlimited
creative variables because of the cost
associated do you can't buy I can buy
eighty eight dollars worth of YouTube
that could be effective you can't do
that on television I can do a thing on
an iPhone you know I think all those
people on television look too slick and
full of [ __ ] I think if you took your
unicorn and he just filmed something on
a [ __ ] iPhone with bad lighting and
you ran that [ __ ] that might come her
better cuz it feels that more authentic
so those are some of the themes as far
as Arizona there's too many variables
for me to give you a thoughtful answer
what I would the the thoughtful answer I
would give you is take advantage of the
fact that it's new and actually do a ton
of different [ __ ] in Arizona to see what
may click because you might get into a
micro insight on a pre-roll YouTube ad
if you're not doing pre-roll YouTube
based on people's search queries you
have to do that so like you can you know
I'm sure there's three four core
competitors you have in Denver that are
trying to do the same [ __ ] you could
actually buy pre-roll YouTube based on
people searching injury or claims or
like this
what you can do for all of you
especially b2b pre-roll YouTube that's
based on what people are searching on
Google is one of the best ads you can
have people you could have a dentist
searching dentist terminology but
happens to be a Gary Vee fan he goes and
watches a Gary Vee video and you're
popping up as the pre-roll that's
powerful some very very hot on pre-roll
YouTube based on Google search query for
that's agnostic and and something I
would do quite a bit of of work and then
I think one of the other things that I
would spend a lot of time on is a hell
of a lot more digital auditing of every
attorney injury personality on the
Internet I think you should invest
whether it's you or the person below you
but no further than that over a hundred
hours of qualitative consumption of
every personal brand trying to convert
on Facebook Instagram YouTube to just
see if there's anything you see one of
the biggest mistakes that one of the
things I've never talked about that I'm
starting that literally it's might be
the first time talk about this what's
good about two weeks vacation you get to
think like [ __ ] I don't I don't know if
I'm articulating enough to people how
much [ __ ] research I'm doing I'm just
now I'm doing it with audience I'm not
seeing what you know Richard Branson is
doing or other I don't do that
I just consume everything my audience is
doing with me everything all of it I
just I'm just reading all the [ __ ]
comments so that thank you got it
so the advice I got yes was yes yes talk
about it yep
good to see him consistent so I started
that the next week got fairly good
results but I struggle my trainer is
exactly no different to me saying look
you should become a basketball player
there's only 15 of them on the team the
salary cap is super high it's a really
good idea to become a basketball player
if you're seven years old right now
because you will make a billion dollars
in 12 years and it's a fairly good thing
to do the next question is are you good
enough to be a basketball player so the
device is right and this is back to
where I'm gonna go with this please make
sure that you don't become and I know
you well enough because of our
interactions I want you to do unlimited
variations and as much as you could be
motivated to do that that is the game
you do understand that one moment you
get a spark of using a different
adjective or it's [ __ ] hailstorm is
outside and you just like it's just one
moment you're literally one moment from
one version of creative and one search
query because it's two creative
processes what are they searching like
the interior thing might be underwear
and I don't want to send you down a
crazy rabbit hole but it is scary to me
that I'm giving you dentist that's
literal but maybe the terminology was
you know MBAs like you don't really know
and it can cost you nothing my big thing
is that production value does not have
to be extraordinarily expensive as a
matter of fact I'm just literally the
thought that just came to mind I haven't
talked about I almost think maybe you
should only do all of it on your iPhone
upfront see if there's a little painter
and then maybe you come in on top of it
and make the production value go a
little bit up on the fact that you found
something creatively this is all bottom
up how many different versions of
content did you do for the pre-rolls
- yeah so that's what I want to
encourage you to like make 89 and then
how many different search queries right
so you're at two or three videos versus
I don't know how many search query
groupings you've done good which is cuz
it's easier and what's interesting is
the creative is probably the bigger
variable and so I think you could you
know don't overthink the creative can I
give me one I apologize
cuz it's intuitive to me I think you can
massively over-index with people that
are 48 to 72 around just like you know
no different than quit and things that
nature I also think you're doing its
generation it's family business there's
a lot of things that are more macro than
the literal nature of what you're
selling there's a lot of people that buy
my wine that are just don't drink wine
just co-signing bad and I think you
represent something for a generation
that might be fruitful something think
about you know not that everybody needs
to become a motivational character or
cap you know but there it's one of the
places it's one of the creatives you
should run you know I'll give an example
terminology around changing your career
or starting a new business at sixty and
then your video is starts right you know
what they're doing so you're starting
with like look how old are you great
like I'm 15 I love this [ __ ] you know
like that may be the reason they convert
you see where I'm going you see people
get too literal I'll give you a good one
for dentistry one of the things I've
been super fascinated with when you read
a ton lawyers doctors and dentists that
are 39 to 62 are stunningly miserable
because a lot of them did it because
they were supposed to or had to that in
itself is a crazy insight for your
business that you can completely triple
down on as a connection point with them
that could transform your business
because it's a human insight they're
part of the generation that still did
what they were supposed to do or what
their dad told them to do or like that
right there cuz cuz they're on cuz
they're unhappy because what they really
were was a rapper
because what they really were was a sign
designer or a wine maker but they had to
become a dentist and I think that is if
you've just leaned into that content if
you start a YouTube video of like are
you a dentist because your dad told you
to that alone will convert scary so
that's something I think you should play
with if you mean five pre-roll videos
just on how to make a successful family
business because you're the son and then
there's somebody underneath you right
yeah dude you're like you're you're
crazy you're perfect
you played underneath and you played
above so you're talking to everybody in
a family business it's kind of what I've
done with my dad and AJ you know like
it's given me the ability to play for
both sides you should do five different
pre-roll videos just on that and against
family business search queries and see
what they do and by the way you know
what's fun about this and the erect
noses with the same level of passion I
do this all time I'm usually happier if
everything I'm saying right now doesn't
work because this is science the nose
are as valuable as the esses and that's
not what television or a booth at a
convention does there is no ability to
play in perpetuity constantly testing in
perpetuity
give me that t-shirt direkt I want to
wear it how'd it start yeah
previous ten years a dentist a designer
and a business person about decide to
spread out side business scratch your
itch scratch your itch dentistry is done
I love it we're all benefiting from that
one of the challenge systemically
business that over time was a new
customer journal product requires Dennis
do I say yes yes about three and half
years ago systemically that you are
bleep you're linking yeah we're leaking
so we focused on that quite a bit and
really a radical change that trajectory
good for you homes by listening upfront
we spent started with got it out and
finding water it's the only way you can
fix the leak the job keep going
totally understand keep you can imagine
how much I love listening and reading
all my comments because if you noticed
what you did for your business is a lot
more fun to just lay in your underpants
and read about versus having to fly
around make sense
keep going so I think and the market for
customer acquisitions in the macro has
changed that is just the punchline
they're just it's like it's very real
like [ __ ] has changed
yeah I've got two objectives really for
the long run it's about brand of course
I love you so let's talk about the Army
versus Navy SEALs okay right the reason
it works is because we do not send the
army in to kill Osama bin Laden that is
sales and branding it can't be everyone
you know and it's not picking a sales
and marketing under one thing all the
way to the top or wherever it goes above
you is a tricky game because inevitably
he's held accountable or about you know
again I don't know the clothes truck but
you know where I'm going with this
everybody [ __ ] up marketing because
they're gonna always lean into sales
because they need to hit short-term
objectives the end that's where
leadership has to come in and create
rules for engagement so I love 80/20
it's why I love Army and Navy SEALs it's
why I win I create businesses like
Vayner that is my foundation of 80 and
then I taste with 20% around it that's
how Boehner X got built and then even
outside the manor universe that's how
the case twists and the empathy wines
and all that this is how it all works
that's marketing because everybody's a
sales like your sales organization so
let's put a little fund on the side or a
little team on the side and that's
marketing and if it goes to dead zero
you've decided at the macro level that
$800,000 to dead zero is super fine by
me because you know it's not gonna be
that zero but now you've created
autonomy and lack of confusion and to
actually make that happen same thing I
told him in the macro it's what I want
you to do that's why I've created beta
Rex
same reason okay here to think we try to
do everything under Vayner here the
things we've learned for these Sasha
minute now it's Sasha and [ __ ] puro
you know and we'll keep going Commerce
is gonna kick out - because kick it out
right now Robbie has to navigate its
organs within bodies create a separate
body sales and marketing is mixed and
that means you're actually doing sales
and if marketing is put into a place
where it's all upside because marketing
is gray it is intuitive right so if if
the rule is 500,000
and I'm Jhelum making [ __ ] up and like
there's nope like at the end of day it's
like if you were the head of it for me
I'd like it's five hundred thousand and
my team will tell you this James will
definitely tell you this it's like I
don't give a [ __ ]
we'll talk at the end of the year
explain yourself but I have no [ __ ]
judgement I'm not booing or cheering
along the game just tell me when it's
triple zero and explain to me why we
lost 112 to 88 or why we won 112 to 88
and you just hold that person
accountable
that's how marketing needs to work cuz
that's marketing you have to be able to
do something ridiculous like buy $50,000
worth of bananas and send them to
dentists just cuz it's so ludicrous
they're like what the [ __ ] you see where
I'm going no like like as as silly as
what I just said to you you you you
would be shocked how smart what I just
said actually is based on how silly it
sounds the world is busy the way you
break through is by breaking patterns if
you're a [ __ ] dentist and you get a
banana sent to you in the mail and you
wrote a note on it in pen that's just
weird weird enough to give you awareness
but what's really fun is when you know
your industry so when you know your
industry and let's say fluorides getting
demonized or the emergence of like you
know I don't [ __ ] know you know but
like and there's something like funny
it's like an inside joke and then that
is your banana now you really got
something yeah right I'll give you a
wine comp bro say so hot that what I
would do is do an anti rose' movement
like I would send everybody a bottle if
I was trying to get the wine retailers I
would send them like you know a
sparkling wine named [ __ ] rose' that
would get everybody's attention because
you would be playing to what's happening
that's so you know what that was that's
just like me telling him pre-roll
YouTube and that that's right what I
just told you is right but what you fill
it with the banana or the that's the
game as you can imagine if you've played
this out this is why I fell in love with
the internet wait a minute unlike when I
was doing print radio and television I
only had one chance to figure it out
now I have 31 chances to figure out if
it's banana or fluoride or [ __ ] rose a
[ __ ] got it yeah yeah and then what you
do is you build a team that makes that
affordable you know like the amount of
money people people are trying to
replicate my model but are overspending
on the tech or the lighting or the
post-production like you know that's not
gonna work if you're running a motorboat
you don't fill it the same way you fill
a cruise ship and it's gonna sink and
that's what people are doing
they're overthinking and then that then
led to the next part which is don't
overthink your content because that
wasn't the physical manifestation it was
the mental manifestation you know you
know many owners and CEOs jump in and
look at their Instagram account and
you're like I don't like that picture
and they're like breaks the whole
machine like that's you know so like all
these things
the pillar versus the micro examples up
shooter like video - what if you don't
have the video to start with already not
sure what should be yes yes it matters
like video is the answer that's the
punch like what video does is allows
everything to trickle underneath because
you turn it into written you can turn it
into audio or you can turn it into micro
video if you don't start with that
you're limited which is okay you know
like but the answer is yes it is highly
important if you can do video now how
you do video is the next debate so where
I always get worried about my own advice
is that people take things so literal
that they may think they have to be like
me
like I can't wait and by the way there's
millions of these people I just haven't
I don't do the homework but you know me
people are super monotone and just
information-based and doing extremely
well on YouTube their podcast they're
not charismatic they don't curse
they just know their [ __ ] that to me
this is utility and entertainment so I
work really well because I do both but
one or the other is more than fine
models and comedians are doing well
because they're bringing entertainment
and escapism and like PhD engineer's can
do well on LinkedIn because they really
know their craft and they 87 people
they're trying to get to appreciate that
right I so you see what I'm going right
like I like to like you could see where
I'm going with the content pillars for
you guys like I love the idea of like
going at the human truth of like are you
unhappy in your profession right like
that just a whole human and I think your
profession uniquely is one of the six or
seven that you can get real upside but
then there's also what I would tell you
on the utility side is put out
information that helps every dentists in
the world that has nothing to do with
your product and service
providing value great so then I would
say imagine that you sold the company
and became dentists daily the number one
provider of information for dentists in
the world and the only rule this new
company is you can't put out content
that had to do with your prior company
and then start pumping out that content
what payment services should use which
app is the best lead gen for you to get
clients why five dentists should start a
micro fund together to invest in
information for them that is massively
valuable as a top of the funnel
awareness once it brings them value my
entire business model is to guilt people
into doing business with me because I
provide so much [ __ ] value that's
what you should do it will work and
crush LinkedIn so like cool now we've
decided the creative thing pound
LinkedIn you can target dentists because
you think that see can give you leverage
oh that's the [ __ ] most like listen
that's the best like this is why I loved
Intel right until it's such a good job
with C as a chip provider that we
weren't willing to buy your computer
less Intel was inside of it
like yeah I mean listen you know nothing
would like now you're talking about the
thing that would be interesting for me
to work on because nothing makes me more
happy than to force some dentist that's
a dick face and doesn't want to use us
to have to use us because we went after
his customers or her customers and
forced him to the best feeling in the
world I love it so yeah I think there's
something there now consumers harder but
you know it's a you know what's ironic
my first intuition on that is parents
are scared
in a way that like is really [ __ ] up
actually and this is the greatest
generation of over fearful parents and I
would probably exploit that I you know I
would pump a lot Facebook will crush for
you on this you know and this is where
you're thinking about basically but at
its most simplest form I'm gonna make
this assumption and obviously things are
changing in our society but still them
sure mom's are making a lot of these
decisions so I would probably target
moms around four to five core messages
around fear to pressure their dentist
then I would do micro testing in places
where you think you have good
penetration of dent like the first thing
I'd probably do if I was part of the
seemed like or where do we have the best
penetration of dentists using us cool
its Denver
okay let's attack Denver and see what
happens because then there's a lot of
options for them to switch versus like
you know convenience is king even if you
scare them that like they're gonna well
you know even if oh [ __ ] my only options
for forty five minutes away [ __ ] it let
the kid cry you know they kind of thing
so that's something to think about but I
would go with videos like whether it's
testimonials whether it's like you know
re-enacting scenes like moms loved it
like everybody but in this scenario like
just literally hiring college students
or starving actors to do like a
two-minute video like re-enacting a
scene they're like is this happen in
your house and like there's a lot of
smart stuff you can do and you're always
one video away that which is why I want
you to make more the Beast the Beast yep
and you know we reach out or listen to
them on facebook you know it's a lot of
like the assistance it's the auxilary
yes you know it's not the casters
themselves is it in person yeah at trade
shows no for instance no yes but I have
a little idea so I'm a big fan of golf
and wine so I think you I think you
should create semi-annual events that
you spent some real madness now mark
this is why marketing spun right flying
in 25 people getting a nice steak dinner
you know like Santa Barbara is good so
you know already like honestly with the
way the wine business is right now I
would probably go knock on every winery
in Santa Barbara inevitably somebody's
like and literally ask for free like
look we're gonna bring you 50 dentists
that have money we want everything for
free want to come to the winery what
does every what the dinner for free more
wine for free no cool
there's 700 other wineries in Santa
Barbara somebody's in trouble
yeah got it I'd probably do that and
then I would run ads or do direct calls
you play two ways you could prospect and
run ads and say hey we're doing this
thing fill out a form we're selecting so
it's velvet rope or if because you want
the information you're tripling down on
your VIPs or I've always liked the B
list you know a lot of people do
everything for their top customers I've
always sucked the B was an interesting
customer right because they could become
an A or you could lose them so you see
where I'm going I could see you're
picking up what I'm putting down so golf
and wine and then anything else golf and
wine are just intuitive to me cuz that's
what I I was in the wine stuff and I
just know people are ludicrous about
going to golf events but there's there
might be something that's really natural
to your DNA it might be rafting it might
be camping it might be bowling but like
creating something somebody actually
wants to do then layering a conversation
and whatever form you do it as you can
imagine wine is super conducive to that
cuz it's a wine dinner you then overlay
the thesis of this is actually dentist
like I started something called agent
2021 because it was like about it was
about you know the bigger thing so maybe
this is not even about you maybe this is
about dentists in this
symposium I always like using the future
so like dentistry 2025 right like where
is it going so it's a conversation maybe
you pull some sort of you know maybe
back to marketing maybe spend five
thousand bucks to have somebody who like
has gravitas in the industry I don't
know the industry well enough for like a
retired athlete carries weight that's
why they pay you know Hank Aaron ten
thousand bucks because somebody wants
that selfie and that got them in the
room and then they got the question they
wanted answered it's just arbitrage it's
just arbitrage but how you package the
arbitrage is the game right when you're
calling me as adventists I know you're
looking for information [ __ ] you not
interested see yeah right you're
inviting me to dentist twenty
twenty-five you're gonna educate me on
what to do on social media to build my
practice I'm gonna be able to play golf
and have dinner and Hank Aaron's are
interested
it's a 79 thousand dollar investment but
the info is valuable and if you spend
you know and back to like what we're
talking about
you make the fifty people twenty five B
clients and twenty five prospects they
can get real interesting real fast
got it so those are all the nuances
you're welcome can't wait
morning they're gonna call them with
happiness or sadness here we go
don't try to leap don't try it out don't
try to lead the witness go you've led
the witness much very similar to the
Victoria's Secret model yeah another
place they're out of Amazon and fine
with that but the answer is you're both
right cuz you know he wants to do full
freaking here will save your life both
we're both right so what do you decide
what business you want to build we want
to build a business where other people
aren't trying to take our customers I
understand that that's all I'm saying
because then you get then you you're
going into the tactic of why you want
your model I'm at you need to figure out
what business you're building so for
example you're looking to run slower
he's looking to run faster
that's what that's the actual
manifestation of this conversation which
is okay if the seven business you're
building right like you know to you it's
your baby
which is why you don't want anybody to
[ __ ] it up to him he's trying to think
about how to grow it quicker he's okay
with it two times returned and I like
the retail dollar he's okay with that's
that's a different conversation I think
and it leads to the next question which
is what business are you trying to build
like like the answer to your question
comes in what do you do you both agree
on where you want revenue and profit to
be in 2025 because if you don't already
the debate becomes convoluted yes
okay well then about what is that
because because if you both agree where
you want it to be in 2025 all I have to
understand is where the businesses is
that now and how realistic the numbers
are predicated on the data and then the
reality is he's probably gonna be right
because it's too short of a window for
you to do it your way
so which is why it's fun for me because
the reason I never want anything in
twenty twenty five or twenty twenty two
or twenty twenty-nine which allows me to
be a marathon runner if I had any
arbitrary number goal ever I'd be a
sprinter yeah I think we have a twenty
twenty eight goal
that's a [ __ ] answer right in a good
way you just made that up like why not
to 13 why not 87 then you know what I
mean right
and I think you need to think about that
I'm giving you that in a love weighs the
same as quit that you also made up why I
mean you might have a very good answer
which is like hey Gary actually because
we want to buy this island for 76
million dollars and if we sell for a
dollar for dollar at 150
that's our post fax money and we gonna
buy this island in Peru I'm like okay
now you're right otherwise you just make
it up [ __ ] predicated on the data that
you're sitting with right now it's just
arbitrary this is how you answer this
question all right you're both right but
the actual cuz you got to make a
decision is predicated on do you have a
number do you want to sell the brand one
day don't you do you emotionally care
about somebody discounting it when they
told you they weren't going to do you
give a [ __ ] don't you the reason so many
things are easy for me is I don't give a
[ __ ] he's using like signature on a
thing I have no idea what the [ __ ] he's
talking about my signature is my most
important IP and I don't give a [ __ ] cuz
I like him and fine it did something
myself I bottles in 15 cases 40 K like
but like you know these people would
freak the [ __ ] out with that yeah like
so like it just matters the answer is
very individual you know there's like
most of the things I do most people
don't agree with most of the things I do
most people don't agree with because I'm
unique in my lack of interest in short
term money and I'm now starting to
debate even money in itself I just like
my process and if you want to choose
your process well then it's gonna happen
slower right and that's okay yes
no because the up let me phrase if you
execute everything properly more
distribution will lead to more revenue
it just it will if both are done
properly if you [ __ ] it up to your point
like look if you do a deal with they
[ __ ] it up you know they do something so
shitty that it hurts your like to your
point it might not but
yes there's a reason that licensed
brands get to hire dollars quicker
because you're the friction of getting
the product I have no idea about your
brand but when I go on Amazon and search
something any brand pops up now I do and
I live on Amazon not your [ __ ] calm
listen James will tell me when I believe
James can talk to you guys about like
why I didn't want to do Jim James walks
into my business like we were getting so
much steel flow and he was really
logically in a great way he's like hey
I'm gonna crate up all these jv's on the
app so I'm just gonna be money people
come in we'll send it to Carol to do
that kind of stuff and we'll get a
commission I'm like no no no and like
you know it's because I just wanted to
create everything for myself I was
willing to go slower we could have made
a lot more revenue but that's like
destroyed it bastards as if brands and
so like it just depends on what you want
that makes sense yeah and it starts with
both how you want it you know and then
how much right I always talk about how
you make your money's more important
than how much it's like putting your
pillow same for you like this is your
baby
easy for him to say yeah you know what I
mean and so you might be fearful what
[ __ ] I was with it yeah for sure
well that but but but but there is no
cake and eating here - you will get to
the revenue faster right you will very
likely what about what about this it's a
crazy idea but what about borrowing
money from a bank this has become the
most fascinating thing for me the fact
that I had a deliverer of that sentence
with this is a crazy idea it was the
only way so enough of us in here that
aren't twenty eight that was it
there was no VC there was no raising
capital there's so much money in the
system that's what happened but you know
why give up a piece your business and
have all that chirping if you're so
confident yourself go get a loan it's
really weird but I'm really into it like
I'm so excited that my hot advice is to
borrow money from a bank and I and I
really like you know like the more
you'll talk this it like makes so much
sense but it's so out of the lexicon in
the business world like I don't know the
last time I heard somebody say it I'm
everything I believe like yeah like we
have a credit line like that was a good
idea I didn't want to give up more
equity bet on yourself people are using
it because it's a fake version of
betting on yourself it's not gonna take
that much money and if the business is
doing great
a bank is gonna feel pumped to get
interest on that you know I don't know
the latest the the landscape of loans
you know not educated but if your
business is doing great I have a funny
feeling somebody's interested in lending
money should I try to double or triple
down on my strengths within each
business as far as scheduling time doing
my thing you personally yes 100% like
nothing I believe in more then the fact
that most people lose is they waste time
on trying to pick [ __ ] that's never
fixable and what I mean by that is what
I mean by that is I'm not gonna be an
NFL quarterback and I'm not gonna be not
a high-energy
do you guys understand that if I was 13%
less high energy that I would be 2 times
bigger there's a lot of people that
can't deal with my energy
do you understand if I didn't curse that
I would have 12 million followers not
six like people don't get it like but
I'm
just a buyer of like being who you are
and to your point I do think in
thirty-year terms you get further just
not in five and then you added three
more but you know what I mean sooner I'm
going I think you're right in a thirty
year window I think he might be right in
a five year window I've got it I could
be so much bigger if I toned it down a
hair cleaned up a little language today
not in twelve years
got it understand that's how I think
about strengths and weaknesses by
actually kissing the girl by actually
throwing the person in the pool by
actually skydiving correct it's the
universal truth everything you were
scared of became less scary after you
did it and then you're like why the [ __ ]
was I scared of that
do you think it's possible for a company
to build a personal connection to their
customers without having person
um yes I do it's how people feel about
Palatine or Nike or Apple but it's hard
but your ambition isn't to be that big
and so in the micro yeah I do
I think it's reputation right it's the
old school [ __ ] but old school [ __ ]
takes old-school tactics right but new
stuff can be gateway drugs to old school
tactics that's the example I gave you
you can recruit 25 new dentists through
LinkedIn for your old school dinner suit
up I use digital to be a gateway drug to
old school [ __ ] and then I get smart
about it like this is old school [ __ ] I
like this how did I make it
much better d-roc films it which could
lead to three pieces of content that
creates top of the funnel for me becomes
even more valuable Q&A is my best format
because it gets me into new thoughts
that I'm not getting to myself
got it the whole framework is built to
make everything work which is why I'm
able to charge so little for the value
because I'm amortize it out out of
getting the content which creates top of
funnel makes sense I love when people
secretly talk to each other from
foreigners like it's really you know
especially like people are getting real
or so it's a real good deal if you
actually do the thing we say you know it
feels great you know I'm an SMB right I
come from this world so it's fun
you